[Musica]
[Applauso]
ne avete aumentata una castagna ma
pentendo posso stare tranquillo che la
maggioranza di voi ne tiene una con sé
ora che autunno arrivato il freddo
perché lo sappiamo tutti che le castagne
e matt e ci proteggono dal raffreddore e
dall'influenza 1918 l'influenza spagnola
vola sul pianeta e fa 50 milioni di
morti
chiude la prima guerra mondiale un
secolo dopo
nell'inverno del 2012 negli stati uniti
12 mila persone muoiono per complicanze
di una severa influenza
l'anno successivo 56 mila e nel
terribile inverno del 2017
ottantamila lo stesso inverno in europa
40 mila persone il 6 per cento dei
decessi è causato da complicanze di
gravi influenze e nel frattempo ma nel
frattempo la percentuale delle persone a
rischio di queste complicanze vaccinate
per l'influenza che la comunità
scientifica vorrebbe fosse di almeno il
75 per cento ogni anno
beh è crollata da un già misero 44 per
cento a poco più del 30 nel 2017
probabilmente perché abbiamo abbiamo
raggiunto nuove consapevolezze ci siamo
fatti delle domande ci siamo domandati
quali sarebbero poi
questi benefici del vaccino che a
sentire a sentire in giro non è mica
chiaro quello che è chiaro è il denaro a
chi li produce ma anche ai medici i
medici che li somministrano intanto noi
dobbiamo sopportare questo sopruso
l'obbligo è correre noi tutti quanti i
rischi dei vaccini che lo sappiamo
chiedete in giro i vaccini ne hanno
moltissimi così sulla prima pagina
l'articolo di fondo del wiltshire times
nel febbraio 1894 leicester regno unito
100mila persone scendono in piazza si
dichiarano obiettori di coscienza contro
la vaccinazione obbligatoria protestano
e urlano il proprio diritto a una
libertà di scelta civile e religiosa
contro questa imposizione del governo
era il 1885
sì perché 90 anni dopo nella campagna
inglese a burke lei un giovane medico
edward jenner aveva prelevato un po di
materiale dalla pustola di un mungitore
di mou che a quel tempo si sapeva che
chi faceva quel mestiere aveva un
rischio inferiore di ammalarsi di vaiolo
e aveva poi inoculato un po di questo
materiale sotto pelle a un bambino di 8
anni quando il bambino era venuto a
contatto con la malattia vera con il
vaiolo dell'uomo intendo venere uscito
miracolosamente illeso
nella stessa contea dieci anni dopo da
18 mila il numero di morti per vaiolo
scese a 180 una riduzione del 99 per
cento nella mortalità per una singola
malattia infettiva e così genera aveva
iniziato a porre fine a 12000 anni di
terrore per una piaga conosciuta fino
dai tempi dell'antico egitto che aveva
fatto oltre 400 mila morti all'anno nel
1805 napoleone bonaparte dopo avere
vaccinato il figlio rende obbligatorio
il vaccino per il vaiolo per l'esercito
e subito dopo per tutta la popolazione
francese e dunque
che cosa ci facevamo tutti quanti noi
all'estero 80 anni dopo uniti urlare il
nostro diritto a una libertà di scelta
sulla base di cosa avevamo costruito
questo giudizio sulla base di una nostra
conoscenza o forse dell'illusione di una
conoscenza 1995 pennsylvania in una
magnifica giornata di sole mccarthy
wheeler pistola in pugno entra la prima
in una banca poi una seconda raffa tutto
il denaro che può e si dilegua prima di
sera verrà individuato e arrestato dalla
polizia
lui è incredulo dice come mi avete
potuto prendere così in fretta
effettivamente mccarthy era entrato in
banca senza nessuna maschera sul volto e
così le videocamere avevano ripreso e fu
gioco facile individuarlo e arrestarlo
ma lui lui non si dava pace diceva non è
possibile il video camere non mi possono
avere ripreso in effetti dice io ho
spremuto il succo di un intero limone e
melo se non messo sul viso e lo sanno
tutti che quando il limone viene messo
su qualche cosa che la rende invisibile
a patto di stare lontano da fonti di
calore io sono stato lontanissimo da
fonti di calore
mccarthy peraltro si era anche scattato
una fotografia a quel tempo per la
verità i self i non avevano ancora
inventati lui aveva usato una polaroid
ma per errore aveva fotografato il
soffitto e così quando la fotografia era
pronta l'aveva presa guardata e ci si
era visto invisibile
prendendo spunto da questo bizzarro
fatto di cronaca
due ricercatori americani si posero un
quesito di quale fosse l'effetto della
nonna consapevolezza dell'incompetenza
ora che mccarthy non fosse consapevole
la propria stupidità
questo probabilmente è evidente ma in
generale dico qual è l'effetto
essere consapevoli di non conoscere
qualche cosa e partiranno da due
presupposti
il primo è che nella vita in quasi tutti
i contesti la conoscenza e quindi la
consapevolezza sono lo strumento che le
persone usano per raggiungere i propri
obiettivi ed il secondo è che ogni
persona a livelli di conoscenze di
competenza differenti nei diversi
contesti
il loro studio dimostra in modo molto
elegante che l'incompetenza non solo
porta a scelte sbagliate ma depriva le
persone della capacità di capire che
quelle scelte sono sbagliate inducendo
una ottimistica sovrastima di una
conoscenza in realtà inesistente perché
la conoscenza che noi usiamo quando
esprimiamo un giudizio è proprio la
stessa che ci serve per comprendere se
quel giudizio è corretto ma per molte
ragioni
l'ignoranza genera fiducia molto più
della conoscenza e quindi quante volte
davanti a molti fatti a molti eventi noi
sostituiamo il dubbio con un limone che
è l'espressione della nostra presunzione
di conoscenza e la conoscenza poi
ma siamo davvero sicuri che la
conoscenza sia davvero l'unico strumento
che ci conduce a delle scelte corrette
1990 università di stanford california
elizabeth newton una studentessa di
psicologia si pone esattamente a questo
quesito per la propria tesi di laurea e
cioè quale sia l'effetto della
conoscenza sulle nostre scelte
di conseguenza sugli altri e per
risolverlo prende due gruppi di persone
al primo gruppo da questo compito
tamburella te sul tavolo delle canzoni
molto famose happy birthday merry
christmas e al secondo gruppo dice voi
dovete ascoltare e riconoscere delle
canzoni che verranno tambur alte sul
tavolo ma prima di inizare dice al primo
gruppo
secondo voi qual è la percentuale di
canzoni che chi ascolta riconoscerà e
loro unanimi dicono il 50 per cento
bene solo il 2,5 per cento delle canzoni
verrà riconosciute ma dunque da dove
origina questa ottimistica previsione e
dal fatto naturalmente che chi
tamburellava alle canzoni e con le
canzoni le conosceva perfettamente ma
ciò che lo studio di elizabeth
dimostrerà in modo molto brillante dal
fatto che quando noi conosciamo qualche
cosa in tanto ci pare impossibile non
conoscerlo ma poi noi proiettiamo in
parte questa immagine sugli altri su chi
abbiamo di fronte e non è detto che
conoscano le cose che conosciamo noi e
così ci diventa difficile ricreare lo
stato mentale di chi abbiamo di fronte e
condividere la conoscenza in modo
efficace comunicare conoscenza
è la sfida globale dei sistemi sanitari
oggi l'europa 2017 in romania oltre
8.000 persone si sono ammalate di
morbillo in italia quasi 5000 circa
mille in germania e in grecia 77 in
francia e 26 in svezia 49 persone sono
morte e la 87 per cento erano persone
non vaccinate la comunicazione in sanità
deve migliorare per farlo non deve
giudicare deve considerare il contesto
deve considerare le persone la loro
forza le loro fragilità
l'ottanta per cento delle informazioni
che noi medici diamo quando sono solo
verbali viene immediatamente dimenticato
ma se se hanno un contenuto aggiuntivo
visivo per esempio in questo caso la
gran parte viene molto più facilmente
ricordata nella scienza in sanità ma in
realtà nelle istituzioni
la conoscenza è il fondamento e la
responsabilità è il costrutto di una
comunicazione che non deve essere il
fine ma deve essere lo strumento per
fare in modo che le informazioni giuste
siano diffuse quelle che originano dalla
ricerca di buona qualità per rendere
così le persone più consapevoli delle
proprie scelte e più libere più libera e
anche di confrontarsi con la sfiducia di
comprendere le ragioni della propria
paura
sì perché quello che noi conosciamo poco
ci fa paura
i vaccini per esempio ha certo certo ci
fanno paura perché i vaccini degli
effetti collaterali ciliano ma oggi noi
sappiamo che è mille volte più probabile
che un bambino veniva colpito da un
fulmine e tre volte che venga
selezionato la squadra olimpica e una
volta e mezzo che diventi miliardario
rispetto alla possibilità che possa
soffrire di gravi reazioni avverse per
un vaccino
vabbè comunque questa sera quando
tornate a casa passate per il parco
ducale perché lì è pieno di castagne
amate e non si sa mai
[Applauso]